thank you so much for talking to Sky
News you're welcome Scott use a new
series coming out but there's a whole
lot of stuff that's happened since
you've been off air so what you're gonna
tackle first I don't know I don't know
we'll see because you know we're still
as we speak we're still two weeks away
from the show happening so a lot can
happen in two weeks nowadays it used to
be very little could happen in two weeks
now almost anything can happen up to and
including there no longer being an
America in which I can do my show
there's an on it's at close to zero but
a nonzero chance that this country is
just ashen planks or you have said that
there's a nonzero chance of you being
deported does that threat still exists
oh you know it's close to zero there is
a chance there is a chance I could be
removed do you really believe that
oh yes sadly yeah I mean I shouldn't
because I haven't done anything wrong
and you know I am I am protected due to
the you know the very helpful pesky
nosov the US Constitution and the First
Amendment really does defend my right to
talk the way that I do here and you
pwned the ability I hope yeah yeah well
it's you know that's the it's one of the
best things about this country it's that
you can say what you want and you know
people can use that gift well or badly
do you get threats or you know does the
White House call you up and say stop
being me about the president I mean what
I mean know that what if if the White
House called us up I'm not that would be
a real problem
I don't think we're really on their
radar or if we do it's more like you
know we have the irritant of a mosquito
I think yeah I don't
I doubt what they pay much attention to
what we're doing so yeah they don't
really complain again they have nothing
to complain about because when we say
they're lying it's because they just
lied about something that's not opinion
that's a fact best offensive if we got
something wrong we would get sued and we
go off the air which is why we don't get
things wrong so yeah we have to get
that's why we have to research things so
rigorously because when you take big
swings it's like they say in the wire
right you come at the King you best not
miss
and so that is the that's the problem
like when you do shows about major
American corporations you have to be
right otherwise they will crush you like
a bug
talking about trust and the public you
know having faith in journalism and
commentary they don't appear to have
very much at the moment Trust trust is
declining in journalism in particular
what do you think newsrooms and
journalists can do about that
that is a confounding ly difficult
question sorry
just because it's hard to know quite
where to begin there like whether you go
to the original sin of where that trust
was lost or whether you try and and also
you don't want to kind of cosign too
much on trust being fretted away in the
news especially in this country just
because this administration is battering
on about it being faking and obviously
nonsensical vain so I think the best
thing but news in general in all its
various forms can do it's just like
rigorous due diligence at making sure
that you can't ring-fence
the ground that you're standing on I
think in the world one of the most
dangerous things we're seeing is people
but passing on information and I think
both the news and as individuals that
probably needs to be a heightened
responsibility to not pass things on as
facts if you're not sure that they are
facts so we've had an idea about how to
celebrate transparency oh yeah live
cameras I heard about that that is like
if if you get ready to bleep this out a
terrible idea are you gonna set anything
up here you're not just gonna put you
there clearly there's warning signs
right because people who work in
business swear a lot yeah right you say
a lot of been asked not to it's also a
delay do your job and a bleep a button I
think wow that bleep a button I'd better
have fresh batteries replaced a lot 24
hours of square
ringing the sky news office I listen I
hate the idea but I am looking forward
to watching it are we gonna appear on
your show
I mean inevitably because I just can't
imagine that going smoothly whose desk
is it going to be near you're gonna get
to choose the shots there's multiple
live camera it's an awful idea
I hate it i it's the worst 30th birthday
present I've ever heard of and on that
note thank you John
we're talking to Sky News